OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF, WE PRESENTED
EVIDENCE IN TEN PUBLIC HEARINGS,
TESTIMONY FROM OUR BRAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, SENIOR
WHITE HOUSE AND CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS AND MANY OTHERS.
TODAY, WE ARE PREPARED TO SHARE
OUR FINDINGS WITH YOU.
BUT BEFORE WE DO SO, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED.
AND CRITICALLY, EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED AT THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, I INCLUDE IN
THE RECORD, A VIDEO PRESENTATION
OF SOME OF THE KEY EVIDENCE OUR
INVESTIGATION HAS UNCOVERED.
>> THERE WERE OFFICERS ON THE
GROUND.
THEY WERE BLEEDING.
THEY WERE THROWING UP.
I MEAN, I SAW FRIENDS WITH BLOOD
ALL OVER THEIR FACES.
I WAS SLIPPING IN PEOPLE'S
BLOOD.
>> AS I WAS SWARMED BY A VIOLENT
MOB, THEY RIPPED OFF MY BADGE,
THEY GRABBED AND STRIPPED ME OF
MY RADIO.
THEY SEIZED AMMUNITION THAT WAS
SECURED TO MY BODY.
THEY BEGAN TO BEAT ME WITH THEIR
FISTS AND WHAT FELT LIKE HARD
METAL OBJECTS.
>> THE KEY THING TO DO IS TO
CLAIM VICTORY.
NO WE WON, OVER, YOU'RE WRONG,
FUCK YOU.
>> RIGHT OUT OF THE BOX, ON
ELECTION NIGHT, THE PRESIDENT
CLAIMED THERE WAS MAJOR FRAUD
UNDER WAY.
>> THIS HAPPENED BEFORE I COULD
TELL BEFORE THERE WAS ACTUALLY A
POTENTIAL EVIDENCE.
>> I JUST THINK WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WAS NECESSARILY HONEST
WORK AT THE TIME.
THAT LED TO ME STEPPING AWAY.
>> GENERALLY DISCUSSED ON THAT
TOPIC WAS WHETHER THE FRAUD IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ABUSED
IRREGULARITIES IF REGULATED IN
THE CAMPAIGN, WOULD THAT BE
OUTCOME-DETERMINATIVE.
AND I THINK HAD EVERYONE'S
ASSESSMENT IN THE ROOM, AT LEAST
AMONGST THE STAFF, MARK SHORT
AND MYSELF AND GREG JACOB IS
THAT IT WAS NOT SUFFICIENT TO BE
OUTCOME-DETERMINANT.
>> I TOLD HIM THAT SIGH DID
BELI
DID BELIEVE THAT, YES, ONCE THE
LEGAL PROCESSING HAD RUN, IF
FRAUD HAD NOT BEEN ESTABLISHED,
UNFORTUNATELY, I BELIEVE WHAT
HAD BEGUN.
>> WHAT WERE THE CHANCES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WINNING THE
ELECTION?
>> AFTER THAT POINT?
>> YES.
>> NONE.
>> ASSOCIAT
>> SO, WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO,
I ONLY NEED 11,000 VOTES.
FELLOWS I NEED 11,000 VOTES GIVE
ME A BREAK.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE THE NUMBERS.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
WE HAD MANY ALLEGATIONS AND WE
INVESTIGATED EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM.
>> DID ONE OF THEM MAKE A
COMMENT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
EVIDENCE BUT A LOT OF THEORYS?
>> THAT WAS MR. GIULIANI.
>> WHAT EXACTLY DID HE SAY?
>> HE SAID WE'VE GOT LOTS OF
THEORIES, WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
EVIDENCE.
YOU'RE ASKING ME TO DO SOMETHING
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE IN
HISTORY, THE HISTORY, OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND I'M GOING TO PUT MY STAKE
THROUGH THAT WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
PROOF?
>> THERE'S A TAPE EARLIER IN THE
DAY OF RUBY FREEMAN AND SHEA
FREEMAN AND OTHER GENTLEMEN
QUITE SURREPTITIOUSLY PASSING
UNDER USB.
>> AT ONE POINT THERE WAS
REPORTS OF PASSING A USB TO EACH
OTHER?
WHAT WAS YOUR MOM ACTUALLY
HANDING YOU IN THAT VIDEO.
>> A GINGER MINT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TARGET YOU?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT
EVERY AMERICAN.
NOT TO TARGET ONE.
>> I MADE IT CLEAR, I DID NOT
AGREE WITH THE IDEA OF SAYING
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND
PUTTING OUT THIS STUFF WHICH I
TOLD THE PRESIDENT WAS BULLSHIT.
>> HE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THAT
HE THOUGHT THE ELECTION HAS BEEN
STOLEN OR WAS CORRUPT.
AND THAT THERE WAS WIDESPREAD
FRAUD.
AND I HAD TOLD HIM THAT OUR
REVIEW HAS NOT SHOWN THAT TO BE
THE CASE.
>> AND I SAID SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT OF, SIR, WE'VE DONE
DOZENS OF INVESTIGATIONS,
HUNDREDS OF INTERVIEWS, THE
MAJOR ALLEGATIONS ARE NOT
SUPPORTED BY THE EVIDENCE
DEVELOPED.
>> WELL, MY FIRST THOUGHT WAS,
THIS IS A TERRIBLE IDEA.
JEFF CLARK CANNOT BE INSTALLED
AS ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> YOU ULTIMATELY TOLD US THAT
YOU DESCRIBED THIS MEETING AS --
OR, NOT THIS MEETING, THE
GEORGIA LETTER AS IT'S BECOME AN
EFFECTIVE MURDER/SUICIDE PACT,
DO YOU REMEMBER USING THE TERM
MURDER/SUICIDE PACT?
>> YES.
>> WAS IT YOUR IMPRESSION THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAD DIRECTLY
CONVEYED HIS POSITION ON THESE
ISSUES TO THE PRESIDENT, NOT
JUST TO THE WORLD, THROUGH A
DEAR COLLEAGUE LETTER, BUT
DIRECTLY TO PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> MANY TIMES.
>> MY VIEW IS THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO DO ANYTHING, SO HE
DID WHAT HE DID.
>> I SAID, HOLD ON A SECOND, I
WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT ACTING AS
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE CAN BE
THE SOLE DECISIONMAKER AS TO,
UNDER YOUR THEORY, AND WOULD
BECOME THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
AND HE SAID, YES.
AND I SAID, ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR
F'ing MIND.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS, YOU KNOW,
ALL OF THE ATTENTION WAS ON WHAT
MIKE WOULD DO OR WHAT MIKE
WOULDN'T DO.
THERE'S A TELEPHONE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YES.
>> THE CONVERSATION WAS PRETTY
HEATED.
>> APOLOGIZE FOR BEING IMPOLITE,
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT SHE SAID
SHE CALLED HIM?
>> THE P WORD.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT IT WAS
ESCALATING AND ESCALATING
QUICKLY.
>> SO THEN IN THAT TWEET, THE
MIKE PENCE TWEET, WAS SENT OUT.
I REMEMBER US SAYING THAT THAT
WAS THE LAST THING THAT NEEDED
TO BE TWEETED AT THAT MOMENT.
IT FELT LIKE HE WAS POURING
GASOLINE ON THE FIRE BY TWEETING
THAT.
>> THEY'VE GAINED ACCESS TO THE
SECOND FLOOR.
AND DOWN BELOW.
>> THEY ARE ON THE SECOND FLOOR,
MOVING IN NOW.
THEY WANT TO CONSIDER GETTING
OUT, LEAVING NOW.
>> THE MEMBERS OF THE DETAIL
TELL US AT THIS TIME THEY WERE
STARTING TO FEAR FOR THEIR OWN
LIVES.
THEY WERE CALLED TO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> APPROXIMATELY 40 FEET.
THAT'S ALL THERE WAS.
40 FEET BETWEEN THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND THE MOB.
>> DONALD TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
AND SUPPORTERS ARE A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
>> WE GOT DEROGATORY INFORMATION
FROM OSHA SUGGESTING THAT SOME
VERY, VERY VIOLENT INDIVIDUALS
WERE ORGANIZING TO COME TO D.C.
>> AS MR. GIULIANI AND I WERE
WALKING TO HIS VEHICLE THAT
EVENING.
HE LOOKED AT ME AND SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF,
GOSH, ARE YOU EXCITED FOR THE
6th?
IT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT DAY.
I REMEMBER LOOKING AT HIM
SAYING, RUDY, CAN YOU EXPLAIN
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON IT?
HE RESPONDED SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT OF WE'RE GOING TO THE
CAPITOL.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
THERE.
HE'S GOING TO LOOK POWERFUL.
>> -- PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES!
>> HE PERSONALLY ASKED FOR US TO
COME TO D.C. THAT DAY.
AND I THOUGHT, FOR EVERYTHING
HE'S DONE FOR US, IF THIS IS THE
ONLY THING HE'S GOING TO ASK OF
ME, I'LL DO IT.
>> UM, WELL, BASICALLY, YOU
KNOW, THE PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW,
GOT EVERYBODY RILED UP.
TOLD EVERYBODY HEAD ON DOWN.
SO HE BASICALLY -- JUST
FOLLOWING WHAT HE SAID.
>> THEY CROSSED THE LINE.
THEY CROSSED THE LINE.
>> WITHIN 15 MINUTES OF LEAVING
THE STAGE, PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW
THAT THE CAPITOL WAS BESIEGED
AND UNDER ATTACK.
>> SO, ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
PHONE CALLS BY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE THAT DAY?
>> NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF, NO.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY PHONE
CALL BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT DAY?
>> NO.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY PHONE
CALLS BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO THE SECRETARY
OF HOMELAND SECURITY THAT DAY?
>> I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT, NO.
>> DID YOU EVER HEAR THE VICE
PRESIDENT SPEAKING TO THE
PRESIDENT AFTER THAT?
>> NO.
>> DID YOU EVER HEAR THE
PRESIDENT ASKING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE?
>> NO.
>> YOU GOT AN ASSAULT ON THE
CAPITOL OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> YES.
>> NOTHING, NO CALL, NOTHING,
ZERO.
>> I REMEMBER TRUMP SAYING
SOMETHING TO ME ABOUT, MARK, WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING MORE,
THEY'RE LITERALLY CALLING FOR
THE VICE PRESIDENT TO BE F'ing
HUNG.
AND MARK HAD RESPONDED SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF, YOU HEARD IT,
PAT, HE THINKS MIKE DESERVES IT.
HE DOESN'T THINK THEY'RE DOING
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> YOU ON THE STAFF DID NOT WANT
MARK TO LEAVE THE CAPITOL?
>> ON THE STAFF -- I CAN'T THINK
OF ANYBODY, YOU KNOW, ON THAT
DAY THAT DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO
GET OUT OF THE CAPITOL,
PARTICULARLY, ONCE THE VIOLENCE
STARTED.
NO.
I MEAN --
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT?
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, SHE SAID THE STAFF.
SO, I ANSWERED.
>> NO I SAID IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> OH, I'M SORRY, I APOLOGIZE, I
THOUGHT YOU SAID WHO ELSE ON THE
STAFF.
>> OKAY.
>> I CAN'T REVEAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
BUT, OBVIOUSLY, I THINK, YOU
KNOW -- YEAH.
>> SAID, GOOD, JOHN, NOW, I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU THE BEST FREE
LEGAL ADVICE YOU'RE EVER GETTING
IN YOUR LIFE.
GET A GREAT F'ing CRIMINAL
DEFENSE LAWYER.
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED IT.
>> GENERAL, DO YOU BELIEVE IN
THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER
IN UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
>> OF COURSE.
>> ANOTHER OFFICER UNCONSCIOUS.
>> AT THE CHURCH --
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
GET UP.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SAY THE
ELECTION IS OVER.
I JUST WANT TO SAY CONGRESS HAS
CERTIFIED THE RESULTS, WITHOUT
SAYING THE ELECTION IS OVER.
OKAY?